des prières et des offrandes pour
honorer les dieux c'est ainsi que les
croyants tamouls commencent leur
nouvelle année sur les pas d'hugh elles
brûlent encens juste à côté des fruits
et des parfums un plateau qui souligne
la dévotion et la préparation du croyant
[Musique]
et le carême corporelle au courant ça
veut dire ne pas manger de viande avait
quand même sérieux et pas de viande pas
de poisson pendant minimum trois jours
et a prié le carême d'esprit ou avoir
une bonne conduite une bonne de bonnes
pensées de la terre avec les deux c2
privations ça nous permet d'avoir de
récupérer l'énergie et des divinités
quand même a annoncé le dieu mais on
veut qu'on peut rien commencé sur va pas
s'adresser à cette divinité aux
divinités donc toute chose qu'on
entreprend
c'est comme dans notre vie à nous quand
on se marie on s'adresse à dieu quand on
est on se baptisent on commence l'année
je le pousse à riz récite des prières on
a moulé en sanskrit ces chants rituels
raconte l'histoire des divinités au
travers de montres a sacré pour cette
cérémonie
chacune des statues a été purifiés
parfumé et revêtus de vêtements de
cérémonie
ben là c'est la pierre sacrée et en noir
la divinité direction de l'inde avec
l'énergie intérieure et ce matin on a on
l'a déshabillé on a fait le bain sacré
avec tous les ponts de ville de lui le
miel le lait tous les ingrédients furent
on a fait le buzz comme comme une
personne en vie et après on a essuyé on
l'a préparé on l'a décoré avec les
décorations
on a mis des colliers de fleurs de
plastique des vêtements comme comme une
personne au temple maryen peroumal des
lobes les fidèles sont venus prier les
divinités
ici c'est le dieu vishnou le
préservateur et le protecteur qui est
adoré c'est lui qui préserve la vie et
le protecteur
donc nous moi bon c'est un problème
assez neuf il ya vingt ans à peu près
mais ça c'est par rapport à mon
professeur qui était un prêtre d'un
temple vishnou hisse donc pour continuer
ce qui est ma mon portrait mais on a
décidé de construire en vue chez nous
chaque tome à sa divinité principal et
tous les tampons des divinités principal
différente ici la devine dépasse pas
celle du phishing par exemple le grand 2
qui base à ces mots louga celui de saint
denis c'est coralie
donc chaque temps passa divinité
principal mais on retrouve à côté on
retour après presque tout les mêmes
divinité la communauté indienne célèbre
ce 14 avril la nouvelle année 5119 une
date basé sur le calendrier lunaire qui
fait référence au jour ou brahma le
créateur créé à l'univers et notre monde
une année placée sous le signe de la
sagesse et de la réflexion tant donald
valletoux vocale soit à tout le monde
une très bonne année et que les ondes
positives viennent proche de nous pour
pouvoir avancer tout doucement dans la
[Musique]